enfants vivent le plus clair de
leur temps? À l'école.
- Je vous accompagne?
- Venir à l'école pour
un rendez-vous médical, c'est
ce qui se passe régulièrement
à l'école Henri-Beaulieu.
- Ma classe est juste à côté.
- Yasmine a pu quitter son
groupe de 5e année et rejoindre
sa mère, venue elle aussi,
pour rencontrer le pédiatre et
la travailleuse sociale, et au
besoin, d'autres professionnels.
- Et puis, à l'école,
elle avait de l'aide avant?
- Plus jeune, Yasmine a été
suivie en orthophonie.
- Je me sens de plus en plus
mieux. Genre, avant, quand
j'étais comme coincée,
on me remarquait pas.
- Ça donne un vision globale
de la vie de l'enfant.
- Outre la table d'examen,
- Je me sens de plus en plus
mieux. Genre, avant, quand
j'étais comme coin
on me remarquait pas.
- Ça donne un vision globale
de la vie de l'enfant.
- Outre la table d'examen,
la salle réservée à la clinique
de l'écon du décor
aseptisé d'un bureau médical.
LIONEL ALBERTI, pédiatre
- On comprend beaucoup mieux
certaines problématiques quand
on parle aux enseignants, parce
que là, on a un accès direct.
Je suis assez... Normalement,
il faut prendre le téléphone.
Pour parler à l'enseignant,
c'est quasiment impossible,
c'est des paroles rapportées.
Tandis qu'ici, on a...
l'enseignant qui va venir
pendant la réunion.
- À partir de ce local
subventionné par le Centre
de service scolaire
te-Bourgeois,
on organise aussi d'autres
services pour les élèves.
Comme la musicothérapie.
- Trois, quatre, et...
♪ ♪ ♪- Comme la musicothérapie.
♪ ♪ ♪
Ici, à l'école, le Centre de
pédiatrie sociale de St-Laurent
s'occupe de 20 à 30 élèves
par an. Et parfois, c'est
au-delà du niveau primaire.
- Tu te rappelles
nos premières re
- Oui.
- T'étais comment?
- Ha! ha! Très stressée, très...
réservée. En fait, je stressais
pour rien, quoi. Là, maintenant,
je suis plus détendue.
Et maintenant, bie
jouer devant des gens.
- Laury-Anne peut continuer
à voir le musicothérapeute
même si elle est au second
maintenant.
LAURY-ANNE THÉNOR, ancienne
élève, École Henri-Beaulieu
- Je parle avec Charles-Antoine
roblèmes, avec qui
je pourrais pas parler avec
d'autres personnes et tout ça.
Et après, bien, on vient faire
d'un instrument Moi, par
exemple, c'est la batterie.
Et ça m'aide un peu
à me défouler, quoi.
CHARLES-ANTOINE THIBEAULT,
musicoth
- Nous, c'était surtout de...
d'aller faire face à l'anxiété
de performance pour qu'on puisse
arrêter de saboter des examens,
puis pas avoir trop peur de
faire des communications orales,
par exemple.
- La proximité avec les familles
du quartier est la raison d'être
de la clinique.
CAROLE ROBINEAU, dir. adjointe
Centre pédia. sociale St-Laurent
- Ici, à Chamran, c'est un
secteur enclavé. Il y a trè
de services qui sont proposés
aux familles et aux enfants.
Et c'est pourtant des familles
qui vivent dans des grandes
vulnérabilités.
VALÉRIE LACROIX, directrice
adjointe, École Henri-Beaulieu
- On a le système d'éducation,
on a le système de santé, mais
la connexion entre
le lien entre les deux, souvent,
est absent.
- Face aux différents troubles
d'anxiété, d'apprentissage,
de compo de défici de défici det
de l'attention, la direction
de l'école ne se passerait plus
de la présence de la clinique
entre ses murs.
n d'avoir
un pouvoir sur le développement
global de l'enfant, pas
seulement son développement
académique, de par ce lien-là
avec les intervenants
du Centre de pediatrie sociale.
- Le pouvoir aussi
d'accélérer les choses.
MONDIANA FRANCOIS,travailleuse e
- Nous, nous sommes là vraiment
pour essayer de trouver le
cile pour
essayer de chercher les services
qui sont plus nécessaires
et adaptés à la famille.
Je pense qu'on fait vraimentére.
- Ça aurait pris un an, ça
aurait pris deux ans, qui sait?
Tandis que là, c'est un enfant
qui va être référé en l'espaced.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Parmi une quarantaine de
centres de pédiatrie sociale,
bien peu ont l'avantage d'être
installés dans une école.
Pourtant, le modèle
fait ses preuves.